now today's topic is misunderstandings
of Stoicism 101 which i guess then i
will try to code in an hour although it
could take probably you know half a day
easily yeah we'll get started and then
we'll see what we get and my guess is in
fact Greg Sadler who is the editor of
voice ISM today blog he's also the
president and founder of Reason IO a
company established to put philosophy
into practice providing tutoring
coaching and philosophical counseling
services and producing educational
resources he works as an executive coach
and ethics trainer for priority thinking
and produces the half hour Eagle series
because as its not-it's well known you
can't take more than half hour of a go
in fact that's welcome to the show yeah
yeah well I and I think this is gonna be
a great conversation because this is
something that we've kicked around as
ideas in other forums like in Twitter
when we manage to meet up face to face
usually involving stoic on of some sort
or another and I know that it's
something that you because you have a
bit more of a large footprint in the
media I think you I think you encounter
these things a bit more than I do but I
get my fair share of them as well and I
know that some of our guests because you
know I see their names have also had to
explain some things to other people as
well so I think it's actually a so let's
we're go ahead remind our audience is
that this is this is gonna go on for
about an hour if we go a little over
okay it's the internet but more or less
that's the general idea
Greg and I are gonna start you know we
have a list of subtopics for today we're
going to get started at some point we're
going to open to Q&A we may open a Q&A
during our in the middle of our
conversation I think once we hit one or
two points and then we're going to open
it and then we'll see what happens and
go back to our to our list of topics
you know it's it's all improvised so
Greg the first one is stoicism with a
little s versus toys were big yes so
what's that all about
there's a couple good articles on that I
think I think you may have been one of
the people who wrote them a while back
when we're really encountering this a
lot you know you see it in like the
Facebook discussion groups or the
stoicism reddit where people are asking
questions about stoicism and they use a
little s and they're usually saying
things like well you know stoicism means
keeping a stiff upper lip or suppressing
my emotion so there there's a whole host
of things that people associate
culturally with stoicism and you know
there's good historical reasons for that
that we could go into later if people
are really interested in but those you
know the long short of it is those sorts
of attitudes or perspectives or
psychological traits those aren't the
same thing as stoicism of the capital
ass which is the actual philosophy and
the practices that go along with it and
and you know there like I said there's
good historical reasons why this
blurring has happened I don't know that
they helped us that much in the the
president where we constantly have to
explain this Hey right and it is it go
ahead you know the interesting thing is
I think it was I may be mistaken but I
believe it was John sellers actually who
pointed this out in one of his books
that all of the most of them the early
istic philosophies their names and made
into the English vocabulary and all of
them right so a Korean ism has become
sex drugs and rock involved has become
you know ism is the so all of them is
kind of meeting into the vocabulary but
in all cases there is a trace of you
know a little bit of truth because it's
true that the cynics work that sneering
at people who are telling them hey you
know you're not purchase my friend
what's up with you
diogenes example right and and and then
I actually can't appoint stored
something so if you look at what we know
of the cynics because unfortunately we
don't have most of their writings there
was a point to what they were doing they
weren't just being jerks to people to be
jerks to people they were the heroines
of God as epictetus says right so there
was some sort of object lesson that was
being presented to other people and
there was some sort of thing that they
were doing to themselves you know I by
the way I really liked when we had
margaret graver as the stoic on speaker
and she talked about the sinner approach
to the emotions as trying to sort of
harden one's one shall i think she's
completely right about that and so they
weren't just being you know i don't know
what would you call them today what
would be the synonym not just jerk but
can hipster jerks you know its riches
jokes yeah yeah so yeah i mean we can
say a similar thing with stoicism yeah
okay sometimes there is not showing your
emotions but what's the point of that is
it - just like control your emotions and
show what a tough guy you are or is it
to try to rework your life so that your
your anger anxiety or fear isn't you
know leading you into doing dumb things
that then cascade until you get dumber
things and make your life more miserable
so should we talk a little bit about
stories as men emotion then so what ways
the proper actual story yeah I think
that's probably one of the biggest
misunderstandings of Stoicism
and it comes about because of this
lowercase s stoicism thing you know the
Stoics I mean we can say two things one
is okay they did distinguish between
what we can call bad emotions
and good emotions and then a lot of
people there's good emotions well yeah
you know rational fear which is caution
and rational joy and and rational desire
they didn't see any sort of rational
pain in that fourth quadrant but you
know that we think we could debate that
maybe their Seneca has some room
therefore properly grieving when things
happen that's right now it does yeah and
you know we and we've talked about this
before like love is an important thing
for Stoics affection
Epictetus talks quite a lot about Phil
Astoria which is the kind of affection
we feel towards those who were close to
and you know there's a sense of joy
right yeah in one of the letters to the
suitor sighs you know there is one thing
that you need to do is to develop you
know learn to feel joy it's like come on
yeah Marcus we're constantly stressing
that too I think you know so that's like
a consistent stoic doctrine from what we
can tell and then you know there are bad
emotions bad not in the sense of like
you know we should look down our nose on
them and say oh you're you know you've
lost your temper therefore you know the
whole world is falling apart but they're
you know they're non-productive they
damaged us in some ways and so you know
the Stoics place all forms of anger in
there but you know no irrational grief
where people are like you know you see
this in movies somebody dies and now
you're like you push everything off the
table and you know slam doors and you
know break things well that doesn't do
any good for anybody
least of all the dead person and we
could go on and on about that but even
with the so the second thing is you know
after we make this distinction even when
we're feeling these emotions that are
problematic that the stores called the
passions the pathway it doesn't mean
that all is lost you know when we when
we have an emotional response we can we
can look at the emotion and we do have
some measure of control habits often you
know if they come to help us but they
also disable us sometimes along the line
but we can we can look at the emotions
as things that have to be transformed
you know that we can pick apart and and
see the judgments that are involved in
it or the assumptions that are involved
in the automatic lines of reasoning and
thinking and then you know maybe we
maybe we can't get ourselves to the
point like if you're me where you're
never angry but you can you know do an
epic you know says and like don't get
angry for a day and then keep track of
that that's right yes exactly
never again
yes right I mean that's that's the thing
but but if you the notion is to try yeah
so the way I have come to visualize or
sort of conceptualize what distorts are
are getting at or at least what is a
reasonable modern interpretation of what
a storage beginning at because you know
that's the other thing we don't need to
be stuck in our Peters is now Scripture
and just because yeah it says so it
doesn't mean that we have to do it as
well but I mean is a reasonable
interpretation is something on the lines
of the shifting emotional spectrum away
from the kind of emotions that is
disruptive to our lives the kind of
emotion that takes over a reason and
makes you think do things that are
disruptive you know negative that you're
gonna likely regret and moving away
toward away from that and moving towards
calculating positively the kinds of
emotions are on the other are more in
agreement with reason meaning that are
the kind of things that it's reasonable
to do that it's that it's good to feel a
certain wire you know and and and you
use an emotion where there that I think
there's also misunderstandings of regret
and and so you know should we feel
regret at all ideally no right but that
would be because we'd never screwed up
in the first place
and so you know you're feeling regret if
we allow that to become irrational or
like oh I'm so terrible nothing is ever
going to be good I mean oh that's not
productive but you know it probably is
helpful for us to feel some of these
negative emotions you know even anger at
oneself sometimes could be helpful I
think when you know you realize what a
screw-up you are like man I need to fix
this or are getting any Miriam oh good
and if I in fact Seneca says that we
cannot avoid feeling you know that's
that that's another place that I point
people to when they say oh you guys are
trying to suppress in which is like no
Seneca says right there you cannot it
cannot be done what you do want to do is
to avoid acting on the basis of anger
while you are angry should not act you
should disengage
you know take a walk breathing you know
the counterpoint whatever whatever words
get a martini you know what whatever
words
and yeah yeah that works for me for
instance and then come and say okay now
let me engage you what the hell was
going on there because sometimes the
anger is you were just saying isn't that
indicative of something going on that we
should be paying attention to sometimes
we are you know angry either ourselves
or at some injustice that we've seen or
something like that
that is not a bad thing it's what's bad
is acting on the basis while you're
angry yeah very true yeah and and I like
that distinction between suppressing
which is what people claim Stoics for
doing or people claim themselves as
Stoics are doing and disengaging and
then re engaging in such a way as to try
to understand what's what's going on
with me so but now we started this
conversation talking about and so I have
a friend I have a good friend who is
definitely a little Esther story yeah
and I know this for a fact
not because I you know his behaviors
clearly you know endurance it's not it's
not this definitely not about avoid
devoted of emotions or anything like
that instance if upper lip but it is his
thing his endurance he can endure a lot
I mean fatty has endure a lot in in his
life more than then I can in fact
imagine any concerns yourself Sisto ik
in that sense it's like well you know
what am I gonna do I mean what am I
gonna complain about this is a situation
I have to deal with it that's a sport
but he's also very clear because you
know we talk to you read actually story
can you don't while I'm not asteroid
capitalized and the reason is not a
spoke of a couple s because you cannot
buy into certain aspects that I think a
fundamentalist or philosophies for
instance cosmopolitan is okay oh right
or or this notion they're the most
important thing in life is is you know
virtue and not and not sister Dexter
malting
therefore he's not as stoic with a
capitalized but there is a sense in
which is a natural stoic with the little
ass and now it's interesting to me to
figure to see this is obviously an
empirical question if in fact people
that are stoic with a little ass maybe
more more prone to then embrace the
philosophy if they discover it if they
if they actually are
exposed to obviously not my friend but
but nevertheless because I hear yeah I
go to Stoick on I hear offices oh I've
always been a star like wait no you
couldn't possibly always be historic
because you didn't know about the
philosophy and you did not know about
the theory but there's something in
there right
yeah and I've seen people saying things
like that in the Facebook just
discussion groups so try I still go to
although I'm getting close to the point
of saying yeah I'm not gonna bother with
ya because there's so much you know
there's so much that just it's like
reinventing the wheel over and over
again but there are a lot of people who
say I you know when I when I read this
stuff I responded to it because I've
been thinking this way my my whole life
you know I guess we could say a couple
things one is there might be some ways
in which one does that where it would it
would naturally lead into at least some
stoic practices and insights and ideas
but there might be some where it's going
to be at odds with it and it would
actually make it more more difficult for
a person to embrace stoicism of the
capital asks the other thing I was
wondering about those do you think we
should talk about people being the
stoicism not being like an on/off switch
you know or you either you're stoic or
you're not but being something like like
you're saying you know your friend can
accept certain tenets of classical
stoicism right but there's others that
they can't maybe maybe it's sort of like
the DSM for mental illness you need to
have like seven and column a and then
you can qualify okay well that's a good
question I mean and that actually brings
brings me to one of the other topics
that we wanted to discuss today which is
when people tell other people oh that's
not story yeah hey that's happened to
you a lot oh yes it happens to me on
tweeter almost every day yeah maybe this
maybe it isn't but I'm pretty sure that
it's bed stories and to tell other
people that it's bad stories so I think
that and why now that's that's that's
something that I think is worth thinking
about yeah it shows a sort of it's
clearly an obsession with X
Eternals right instead of worrying about
one's own development one looks for
other people to criticize or to teach or
however we want to put it and it's sort
of like a busybody miss you know which
is going to be counterproductive and and
it strikes me that a lot of people
engaging in it
because I've tried to engage in
conversations with some people doing
that they don't want to look very
carefully at what they're doing or the
assumptions of what they're doing right
and in fact it does Epictetus says
pretty much explicitly that you
shouldn't do that kind of busybody right
it's it says in the ingredient there is
a bit of you know where he says don't
talk too much especially about yourself
yeah don't don't talk about gladiators
and other things that's an easy one to
follow but but there is there's a number
of places where in the stoic geyser
would they actually do say it's like
this is not other people's behaviour
isn't your business that's that's their
issue that's their problem
and of course from an epoch from the
picketers perspective the main reason
for it is you don't control it it's out
of your control
now that's you to raise a sort of
paradox though right because that is
well who's who's to teach anything right
and clearly we don't want to just
dispense with teaching or guidance
altogether we do want to say that like
some people have attained more insight
than others we I mean we don't just say
that they're sages in the process so how
do we hold on to that and yet say don't
be a busybody oh I have my way my way
out which is very self-serving I said
you know the only exception is if you're
a teacher if you're a teacher then of
course you can tell in fact and potatoes
does that right yeah this course is
there several places where it does the
like to address is your student says you
fool or just like what are you doing
here right but he's the teacher and
they're there on purpose right they're
not it's not like you know that they're
actually there to hear from him to learn
from him it's not like he's going around
randomly in fact there is a bit where he
does say oh I used to go around the
streets of Rome telling people what is
what to think and
punch me on the nose now it's
interesting that you bring up the
teacher thing because both of you and I
are you know teachers who have a lot of
experience in the classroom and we also
have a lot we've had a lot of peers over
over time and and we've also had our own
professors right as we are coming up now
if you can tell me whether your
experience matches mine I would say that
about you know maybe half of my
colleagues are not very good teachers
and I wouldn't have been that's
conservative yeah I wouldn't really
trust them to be guiding people about
how to apply philosophy even if their
philosophy professors so we don't want
to just say well the you know that being
a teacher per se is the me out for that
right we'd still have to have and some
of them are in fact busybodies you know
yeah I completely so let me actually
qualify this is really important for
education and after this I think I'm
gonna open it up for first round of Q&A
so if you guys are interested in asking
a question just raise your virtual hand
not the real one because I can't see
everybody you know almost 90 people in
the room so I can't say every but the
little virtual hand I will be able to
see it so but yeah that was a very good
that's a very good point so when I what
I mean by featuring this in this context
or even by philosopher frankly is
somebody who is teaching or who is
practicing philosophy in the way that
we're talking about not a licensed
teacher by the state okay yeah yeah yeah
right and not even some philosopher in
the sense of somebody with a PhD I mean
you probably familiar with these series
of studies that I find very funny they
come out a few years ago that showed
that professors in moral moral
philosophy are not more ethical than
your average academic right yeah
although I I was a bit worried about the
way the studies set up in the practices
yes there are some pathological issues
there but I do think it actually does
and to tell me whether you you know on
your side it certainly does map on to my
experience which is that high peers in
ethics aren't particularly good people
right and fortunately the study being
show that they were particularly bad
people
but so the first time I remember
actually distinctly the first time that
I read the study the first study cuz now
there's been a number of them first when
I said come on this this is this is a
little bizarre the must be that might be
some it mythological issue which you're
right there are but nonetheless when
they were repeated over and I was like
okay well there's something that needs
to be addressed here and my first
thought was well that's that's really
odd that's not your expectation right
and but then I thought why not because
in fact teaching moral philosophy today
as absolutely nothing to do with
practicing the art of living you don't
get hired because you're Socrates or
epictetus you get dire because you've
wrote a really highly technical pieces
on an you know tiny teeny tiny little
portion of what somebody else has said
you know probably it's centuries ago so
yeah I wouldn't expect that train to to
to match at all and sure enough they
don't yeah it's not a surprise and you
know the curriculum to there's so many
people I know who their their view on
what ethics is is well you teach a
little bit of utilitarianism and some
can't
and some Aristotle for for the the
virtue ethics but you like you know
totally sanitize that and now you're
done yeah do a couple cases and let's
let's take the first question from Tim
let me Mike
Dave go ahead hi can you hear me yes
okay
you mentioned in passing the difference
between constructive regret or anger and
not constructive in the passion type
were what the line be between
constructive like regret or
self-criticism and like non-productive
regret or anger I don't think that you
can draw a you know applying to
everything sort of line I know you can
certainly say that some things are
clearly way over on the side of that
imaginary line but this is where like
the virtue of prudence would come in and
help help us to ask the right questions
in a situation so you know Massimo was
talking about anger as a response to
injustice and and there might be some
cases where the response
one feels and we could use other terms
to it you know being rightfully
indignant or things like that the seeing
injustice taking place maybe maybe the
the response should be stronger in some
cases and weaker in others right so for
example I'll just take one from our
local state here you know Wisconsin has
made the news recently because of the
shenanigans having to do with our
governor imposing a state home order
which was very prudent and wasn't really
that oppressive and then being sued by
the opposing party which has been trying
to hamstring him since he was elected
and to go at going to the state Supreme
Court which is dominated by that party
and I'm just taking away the order
altogether well a lot of people were
quite upset about that including myself
and and I think thinking about how many
people are going to be placed in harm's
way it makes sense to feel some anger
but then the question is well what do
you do with it right
it's Seneca says and I think you know
I'm gonna turn over to Massimo to answer
the rest of this Seneca says anything
that you can accomplish with anger you
can accomplish with rationality as well
and it's more reliable and I think
that's part of what you were talking
about before we don't just stick with
the anger same thing with the regret you
know you don't want it to wallow in not
just self-pity it's not really even
self-pity it's more like self laceration
but you know you can say well is this
actually constructive is this helping in
any way or do I need now to to like turn
it over you know pass pass it on to
reason which which first Stoics is
effective yeah that's right yeah well I
like about Senecas treatment of anger is
this exactly this distinction between
you know on the one hand it is it may be
a warning bell and it certainly is
unavoidable you cannot you cannot avoid
feeling that the swelling of anger under
certain situations but you should never
act on it and I loved the way he
responds to directly to his tatl because
we thought actually talks about action
he wasn't using anger in action not just
as a warning bell
and any subtle example is you know you
want your soldiers to be a little bit
angry when they go to battle because
then they fight better and you know the
more willing to fight Patrick says yeah
and and and Seneca says well you know
drunken soldiers are also a little bit
more willing to fight but that doesn't
mean drunken army in fact that is
interesting to some studies on modern
fighters you know in like forests in the
ring boxers where the most effective
ones are the ones that actually are able
to maintain calm white getting your
opponent angry because if you if you get
your opponent angry then the guy starts
swinging you know it random points and
very wildly because he's angry it does
not control what he's doing and so he's
wasting energy and opening himself up
and then you can punch him so there's
some extra critical you know it's it's
funny because Aristotle himself talks
not in terms of boxing or anything but
he talks about that as a tactic in
carrying out arguments with people I
think it's in on sophistical reputations
he talks about this technique of doing
something that will tick off your
opponent's so they'll they'll become
less effective and say stupid things
alright Jim is next yes yes Greg you
mentioned earlier that you think regret
can be a good thing and I I wonder if
that's something that necessarily can do
true in the context of service ISM
because it's regret is wishing that you
had done something differently in the
past as opposed to remorse which I think
can be useful in hoping that you will do
something differently in the future do
it just I don't I don't see that
distinction and there's a lot of there's
a lot of ways of like trying to define
the emotions I don't see a lot of people
talking about remorse as a
future-oriented emotion usually it's
it's like regret it's about something in
the past but I I think that it can be so
it's qualified ly good right it's
qualified ly helpful
would be better if you didn't feel it at
all but if you have screwed up it's
better to feel it than not to feel it
because then you can use it to help
guide you to not doing that sort of
thing again
right and again Aristotle also says
something similar with shame he says
well I can't call shame of virtue
because you really shouldn't feel it at
all this is in the nick of mccain ethics
book for but he talks about it in almost
a counterfactual way that you don't want
people to be shameless and do things and
then not feel any sort of and and what
he's calling shame could be translated
also as regret or remorse you don't want
them to do that because then they're not
going to see any significance to what
they're doing being able to see the
badness in what we've done can help us
to I mean there can office to do two
things one is to try to fix it to remedy
it or make up for it and then the other
is to see you know to focus more closely
and what's wrong with me that I keep
doing you know I'm gonna take one more
question right now and then we'll go
back to because I want to cover a couple
of other topics with Craig and then
we'll get back to questions hopefully a
little there so the next one is Dan go
ahead hey Greg okay actually having a
conversation on Monday about certain
things on this topic and one is late
according to my research does that mean
I should just you know live in that like
Darwinist idea of nature and like the
survival is here the nature red in tooth
and claw right right are they or or
monster nature and as long as the nature
there you go
I'll mention to Dan who you just seen is
my co-host for the wisdom for a life
show that's what he was he was referring
to and we've talked about stoas and so
much that we decided to record an
episode just on stoicism that'll be
coming out in the near future so what do
you think about in accordance with
nature I know what you say in your book
yeah well so living according to nature
it's one of those fun you know great tag
lines or you know bumper sticker things
which however I guess it will be a
bumper chariot yeah more than but um
which is it's a great face but but it
does
unfortunately open itself up to you know
lend itself to a bunch of Miss
consumption the most common one being oh
yeah so everything that is natural is is
good well that clearly is not the case
that would be an appeal to nature it's a
it's an elementary logical fallacy and
the Stoics were a little better than
that they face with three but devious it
was was you know high up in the logic
stuff so so that's clearly not what they
mean and it actually very clear about
what they mean because they do elaborate
on it i my interpretation is that it
needs to focus on what our normatively
the best aspects of human nature the
most fundamental and best aspect on
human nature which come down to be two
aspects our high degree of social
sociality sociability and our ability to
reason so
so when Seneca says you know virtuous is
is simply right reason and when Marcus
reader says you know due to what is
reasonable for a social being what they
mean is you should use your brain power
to improve society to improve the human
Cosmopolis that's that's what living
according to nature I interpret it to be
it definitely doesn't mean that anything
is natural is good it's certainly not a
preview of social Darwinism or or or
anything like that but about what
supports your technique you have a high
income and I think that's entirely right
and you know the the there were
interpretations on it that are given in
arias didymus there's like a whole
passage raised like the stomach say this
here's what they all the different
things they mean by in accordance with
nature the one thing I will say is that
it is kind of a complicated topic when
you start mapping out all the different
references to it some of the things that
they thought were in accordance with
nature back then seem to be more
culturally conditioned yeah you know I
don't think we all have to have beards
obviously my um you know you're in a
terrible condition and absolutely
pretty pretty short yep looking around
and all the all the people it looks more
your beard looks a little bit too
suspiciously of Italian it's a little
too well and let it grow out what's all
epictetus would be happy right but not
too much otherwise you become a cynic
and yeah it's sprout it's it's unruly
and so then I get tired of it and I and
then I trim it and then it takes a while
to grow back out again but you know
they're going back to in accordance with
nature I like that you point out that it
really does have to do with our social
nature and you could think of it as as
now the stomach don't say this but you
know living in accordance with nature is
sort of transforming our animality we're
the rational animal and we have all
these drives that other animals have and
you know we do in fact this is why why I
was joking a little bit about lobsters
and that's honestly a reference to
jordan peterson but he no he talks about
these dominance hierarchies ok those do
exist and those don't have to be our
destiny though and so what it means to
live in accordance with nature is to
sometimes trim off some of this this
stuff and Amin ourselves away from it
right in fat Peterson does commit work
that comes very close to committing the
appeal to nature fallacy because he's
basically saying oh our our keys are
natural therefore yeah what are you
complaining about or gender rules are
natural therefore was like and know
they're for nothing you know and that's
actually a great segue into another sort
of thing that we wanted to talk about
which is like stoicism and the red pill
and the sort of like anti feminism stuff
I mean it's very clear I mean the Stoics
weren't weren't the first philosophers
to say men and women basically have the
same capacities Plato says that in the
Republic and as a matter of fact he
doesn't even think that men and women
all have exactly the same capacities he
talks about some of us you know being
more thematic than others and he says
women can be just as thematic as men
they can be just as rational as men they
can be just as appetite of as men so you
got to figure out where people fit into
the society but it seems pretty clear
that that you know Zeno thought that men
and women ought to be treated the same
I'm really glad that we have Missoni
office
telling us that both men and women need
to be trained and hurt you two the same
same degree and you know that a genuine
marriage is not the guy on top and the
woman on the bottom but it's it's a
meeting of equals you know and then he
said there's an interesting mix of as
you might you would expect of course
between so the principles that I think
are in fact entailed by the philosophy
congruent with the philosophy and then
the local the influence of the local
customs of the town like take take
Seneca Seneca it's great for this
because it's not unusual if you read
Seneca - from a modern perspective to
cringe a little bit because he often
says you know you don't want to be a
woman about this you know that's a penis
- in epictetus as well this is a woman
thing kind of thing but then in the
letter of consolation to Marsha
he says explicitly oh you think that I'm
telling you these things that I
shouldn't be talking talk to you about
this because you're a woman but in fact
it's clear that women have the same
capacity for philosophy and he says the
same thing to his own mother
Elvia when he says you know wishing my
father had allow you to you know pursue
philosophy because you clearly have the
you know the ability to do so so when
when I see these kind of contradictions
I think it's reasonable I don't think
it's in any way begging the question or
acting in a sort of selective way it's
reasonable to try to separate what money
being the the local custom the local way
of you know saying things and so on and
so forth which we obviously need to
discard because we don't live 2,000
years ago or to note in ancient Rome
from what actually is entailed by the
philosophy and the philosophy as you
were saying clearly states that work its
cosmopolitan and yeah we're all unique
we sharing the logos for capable
rationality then we're all on the same
on the same level on the same plane so
that clearly is the philosophy then with
it with a petite azure Seneca you know
occasionally slip up and talk about you
know don't be a woman yeah that's yeah
that's why that's why I actually want I
quote them I actually take those
passages away because they distract from
or even rewrite them yes
distracted I do a similar thing when I
when I train
passages from the Greek or Latin and I
don't just do this for the Stoics you
know anthropos I don't I don't like to
translate as man I translated as human
being or a person or you know so so we
don't wind up excluding people going
back to the the sort of red pill thing I
mean I think you've seen a lot of this
where people appropriated stoicism and
they focused very much on this notion of
virtue but they they really left out the
temperance and wisdom and justice parts
just to focus on what they took as
fortitude and you know they they would
construe that as manliness then exactly
and then they point out the funny thing
is that you know when people want to be
experts and they're not right so they're
laughing yeah that's true but you do
know that the Latin verb was a
translation over there which doesn't
mean man at all it means excellent so
for you guys that you might be so like
what are you doing here you're picking
and choosing whatever whatever you like
um I do find that the bruises um's it's
referred to read bills stories and
problematic but at the same time I kind
of expect that sort of stuff to be a
byproduct of the success of stories
right I mean just like yeah other
religions or philosophies then get
destroyed it and you know once it become
popular they get distorted and used for
I mean think about in the case of
Christianity the prosperity gospel I
mean if there is anything that is not a
Christian is the prosperity gospel and
yeah and there's a similar red pill
thing happening with with Christianity
too like a super stress on the Crusades
and you know that whole use of the term
Deus vult as like kind of a code word
and yeah but I mean a reading of the
Gospels would I think you know not just
skimming one's eyes over to actually
thinking through taking the Sermon on
the Mount seriously probably meditate
against that exactly and the same goes
for besides sources as we were saying
earlier it does have an advantage over
Christianity let's say that is we don't
think of
versus God and you know the encouraging
is not Scripture so okay I mean the
other day somebody actually pointed out
to me a really interesting little
passage that I neglected in the
discourses where Epictetus seemed to say
to invoke a notion of self-deception as
sometimes useful and this was in the
context of a completely different
discussion about William James will to
power so I I didn't remember so I
actually went in check that particular
passage and you know I'll share with you
after the show and so you let me know
what what you said and sure enough it
does seem to say something along those
lines
you know I rather be deceiving myself
into you know virtuous behavior that is
like okay but then I thought but why
would you deceive yourself and purge the
virtuous behavior if you understand the
philosophy you don't need to deceive
yourself but whatever is and whatever he
meant fine my response on this was on
Twitter my response was well lucky for
me I don't think of the discourse is the
scripture so if a potato says that
interment that too bad for every data
and we can also say sometimes people do
have to be like cajoled or deceived or
you know tricked into doing something
that's good for them because they can't
recognize it at the time and then after
they start practicing they can they can
turn back at the end say oh man I was
dummy I didn't I didn't actually need
that to get in here well I needed it but
but one doesn't mean it and now I can
get rid of them right let's suppose for
a second take a couple more questions
next
Joseph is next oh go ahead
thank you and thank you for the
presentation today I very much
appreciate it both of you taking the
time today my question is fairly simple
it's you know stoicism you know
basically you know living in accordance
with nature or virtue is its own reward
and it makes us good citizens but would
it be improper if I were talking to
someone and explaining it to
that it's a way of becoming self-aware
yeah would that misrepresent it in any
way shape or form I know it
that stoicism obviously by understanding
what is in your control and not in your
control
then you're becoming more self-aware but
would it be misrepresenting it if I were
to say to someone directly this is a way
of becoming self-aware I don't think so
as a matter of fact the only way in
which it would be is if you said it's
only a way of becoming self-aware and
one of the things that we were going to
talk about is the tendency to
oversimplify stoicism you know there's a
great letter by Seneca where Luke Ilyas
asked them hey give me some quotes and
and they're called Maxim's of course in
the translation but and Seneca begs off
by saying you know first off stoicism
doesn't really work that way it's not
just a bunch of little tiny bits and
pieces it's this you know come complex
system where all of these things fit
together and then he says and if I was
gonna try to give you any quotes it
would be a futile thing to do because
they're all just as good as he is the
next one and you notice like the
discourse is a very long book and Seneca
writes them some you know quite long
books as well so this this notion that
stoicism is basically just this this and
this the you know those are sort of like
entry points think of them as like doors
right and then you're in this gigantic
edifice that's kind of like a medieval
cathedral there's all of this stuff and
you look around and and you know if you
if you come in for just a while it's
like when we could go into Notre Dom
before it burned down you know there's a
lots of other tourists in the way and
you can only see so much at one given
point but if you're spending time or the
day-in day-out you'd obviously come to
appreciate the the complexity of the
Cathedral more so I don't see any
problem with telling somebody stoicism
is is this when it really is that in
part provided you're not saying it's
really only this you're not making it
exclusive right yeah because
self-awareness
you know I thinking is then you need to
qualify
because you know it depends on what you
mean by self-awareness I mean he mean
the biological function that we are
aware of being so obviously not there's
something more to it but yes I do think
that self-awareness is probably part of
it yeah mark is next mark mark mark is
on the phone so there may be a problem
hmm yeah I don't think that I can get
mark so let's go to the next one at
least not for now who be us AWS hey yes
so Epictetus mentions that our body is
outside of our control and lately I I've
learned that our stomach and our hearts
have neurons so they can't think they
can feel and they can take action on
their own and our brain does the same
thing so where does our rational mind
lies that yeah that's a that's a great
question Greg you want us get started no
I don't want to turn that 105 you have
that you know the much more extensive
background I'll give you first crack
then I think that even the stories where
we're obviously they had no knowledge of
modern cognitive science or biology and
etcetera etcetera right but they were
clearly aware of the fact that some of
our mental life it's actually not under
our control this is kind of implicit in
a dictators it's actually explicit in
Seneca because one is when he says you
know you don't control your anger for
instance you can you cannot stop it that
means because you have these these
feelings and these thoughts that are out
on our autonomic there they come to you
automatically you don't control them and
so I I think that the Stoics and petit
especially insists on the fact that the
part you control is only your deliberate
you know that whatever it is you
deliberate on so you're pro hi Reese is
your little know
yourself is basically just limited to a
tiny part of what we considered you it's
not the body and it's not even the
entire brain for one thing the storix of
course then the ancients thought that
actually side of the seed of the
Priory's it was the heart not not the
break they were wrong and now there's
there's one thing that they would have
only wrong about to invite that to
though all right so what was that Galen
bought that yeah yeah actually at some
point it did actually correct because of
it but so the point is they even even
they were aware that even the mental
life is definitely not entirely under
our control
now modern research confirms that to a
large extent and in fact the part that
we that count as you know about the
surface and it's the kind of stuff that
we actually have delivered we can
deliberate on it's actually fairly
fairly small it's what you know the
Daniel Kahneman is famous book about
Thinking Fast and Slow called slow
thinking the slow thinking is over the
system - I forgot which one system one
in which one system - but anyway one of
the two systems is the one that allows
deliberate to slow down and to take
things into account but most of the time
which we think with system with the
other system with the fast one we just
reacted to stuff and you can actually
see part of stoic training and got a
major goal of story training as in
allowing you to slow down and you know
when a bit either says look at these
impression and don't just act on it
right and so don't don't just do it slow
down and think about it and it will turn
out that more likely than not you
actually don't want to do it but in
order to arrive at that body position
you do have to slow down so there was
some kind of intuition that we react too
fast to two things now that said there
are modern skeptics not in the sense of
the ancient philosophy at all but let's
say people like Jonathan Hyde for
instance raisa correct social
psychologist who's been writing a number
of papers and books arguing that
essentially you know we're just under
lucien that we control anything at all
we are in reality we rationalize all
even our rational thinking given our
deliberate thinking sexually a bunch of
rationalizations
I think he's going too far there first
always going to find even just on the
basis of the evidence but also it's kind
of you know if you actually follow it
all the way there then it becomes a self
contradictory proposition because you
know why should I believe Jonathan
height Sam is also rationalizing all the
time anyway
now he does have a point that we do rush
even our our rational thinking a lot of
it is in fact rationalizing and in fact
the evidence is clear that the smartest
and more smarter and more educated
person is the better they are
rationalizing their physician whatever
they want to do they can come up with
all sorts of reasonable excuses for
doing it but again I would actually push
back and say that a big part of story
training is not only to slow down but to
improve your Faculty of judgement to
counter our natural ability try to
rationalize which I think the Stoics
were actually aware at least and an
intuitive love they'll be my take on
that stuff Greg why don't we talk about
this notion that there are some at which
we kind of been dancing around this
notion that there are some ideas that
are this destroyed there is a single
idea that its core to stoicism and then
other person of dispensable what what's
going on there
I see this happening a lot in the
discussion boards about stoicism where
people want to say you know it's the
dichotomy of control and everything else
doesn't matter you know and and it's
that's just not the case if that was
what you know Seneca and epictetus and
Marcus Aurelius thought they would have
written very short books they would just
be an apparent Diogenes Larry taste as
people who had you know single clips and
and I think that some people you know
they might say only that that's fine you
know those old guys wrote that stuff but
now we're in you know the modern period
now we can we can boil it down and we
can simplify it and make it you know
just maybe seven principles or you know
three principles or something like that
and it you know the stoicism is in the
isn't the only approach that people have
tried to do that with but it never
really works well you know because
reality is complicated and the human
mind is incredibly complicated and so we
need many principles and many practices
just to get a handle on it and I don't
see why we would want to throw away all
the stuff that we were fortunate enough
to have and when we've lost Donald and I
at one point Donald Robertson and I we
sat down we tried to figure out how much
of stoic literature do we probably
possess and his take and I think he said
something like 11 percent you know and I
was like that seemed very precise yeah
well in a lot of it was Seneca you know
because Seneca we have so much more of
him than we have of others and it might
be it might be 20 percent it might be 5
percent but clearly we don't have most
of what they wrote so what we do have we
really do want to hold on to and make as
much use out of as we can yeah no I
agree
the notion also of sort of want me to
phrase it this way one of the things
that I moved to the United States one
time a long time ago now like you know
we got a quarter century and but one of
the things that struck me is interesting
about the American ethos to some extent
is that there are a number of phrases
that are typically American and I never
hear in Europe such as the bottom line a
silver bullet this tendency to just like
put it down into a very short list of
things that are actionable right here
right now and that's it done the
European perch tends to be a little bit
more now actually company I mean omerta
Waco famously said you know there's
always a simple answers right for every
complex question is usually wrong that's
that that's the problem with simple
answers so I complete with you I don't
think we should try to boil down things
that's another phrase no I mean it's
it's an interesting it's a it's a
tradition it's a philosophical tradition
that is very rich and as you say it's
it's too bad that we lost probably 90%
of it already so why would you want to
offer us throw away the rights or most
rest so just that it
fits on whatever list of predetermined
numbers is always seven or ten or three
or something like that
because those are the four numbers of
beep from from people no let's let's
talk about what these ideas are sure
some ideas may be more useful than
others today some of them might be more
fundamental in a sort of philosophical
sense to you know the entire the overall
architecture of Stoicism
but to reduce it with just one thing and
then get rid of it it seems like weird
however I do have a question for you
related to this so I've been in an on
and off discussion with Chuck the editor
of historic magazine and and yes some of
that in yes right yeah and and he's been
a really long discussion on a platform
called letter wiki with Tim LaVon about
the same topic I think they exchanged
something like almost 20 letters about
this so here's the thing what he calls
stoic minimalism right so he thinks that
he's a argues that essentially the only
thing we need is ethics the other two
components of the stoic system that is
physics
meaning natural science and metaphysics
and logic meaning not only logic but
currently science and all that sort of
stuff yeah just like the out of the way
and essentially that that position has
been actually proposed in the Easter
stories isn't for instance by a wisdom
before you know so one of the very early
stories yeah and sure enough he left the
school at some point because people
started pointing out to him that well
essentially what you're talking about is
cynicism not stories many more um so
what's your take on that well what the
what it what is it that we should retain
trim stuff because it's on the one hand
so this was Chuck's position but on the
other on the other hand I do understand
of course and agree that there are
certain parts especially stoic physics
that are not acceptable no what else
right so the logic is fine historic
logic is propositional logic and
propositional logic is perfectly you
know fine today we don't actually need
any more than that we don't need
advanced types of logic to deal with
day-to-day problems
it can be integrated with kind of
science with no findings from science
etc but it's an integration it's not a
rejection and then in the metaphysics
yeah I don't believe that the
universities of living organism doubt
but the logos so yeah that part has to
go as far as I'm concerned but does that
mean that we should reject the entire
notion that metaphysics is irrelevant
you know I well I I don't think we
should reject all of the metaphysics I
mean some of some of the things that the
Stoics are saying about the nature of
substance is quite interesting and you
know might be plausible but but so the
logic part right so the logic does
include what we do these days call logic
but it also includes what they were
calling dialectic back then which is
processes of inquiry and how to you know
sort of carry things out I think it
would also include what we nowadays call
epistemology and right you could argue
it also includes semiotics so it's it's
a pretty wide range and I don't see any
reason why we'd throw it out and
epictetus has a great response to this
you know there's a chapter you know this
where he he's got a student who's got
this very practical I don't need to
learn I just need to learn the ethics
part I don't need the logic part he says
Bob go ahead and try that and then when
you come crying back to me about how you
got you know bamboozled by somebody who
you know seduced you with an argument I
guess you're gonna start studying
logically and there's this tendency
there's a little bit of digression
there's this tendency in epictetus that
I don't think is there in Seneca and
isn't there Marcus Aurelius and
definitely isn't there mu Sonia's Rufus
where epictetus is like willing to say
to his students listen if you think
you're smarter than the Stoics try your
nonsense out see where it gives to you
and then we'll you know after you've got
it out of your system we'll come back
and talk about this exactly so but my
take on what we should do today in terms
of sort of the physics the logic and the
ethics is that what what is important is
to retain the kernel of the original
idea and I think the kernel religion
idea wasn't this particular
6 or this particular aspect of logic it
was the notion that in order to live a
good life you ought to know the best
that there is to know out there about
how the world works because if you are
profoundly miss misled about how the
world works
you're not gonna likely live a good life
and you ought to know
but you ought to reasonably think of you
know you have to be able to think
reasonably about stuff otherwise you're
going to both misinterpret the physics
and not live you know in good you know
not understand a good ethics that I
think is internal so this notion that an
understanding of the world the general
understanding of the world not a
specialized a understanding of the world
in a general ability to think correctly
are fundamental otherwise you find
yourself living an ethics that is
entirely derived from other people's
opinions and it's not your thing you
don't own it yeah that's that's a very
good way to put it I don't know that I
have too much to add on that particular
topic well luckily we have only a few
minutes left and we've got a couple of
other questions so why don't we try Tim
you were mentioning before about not
being a busybody and providing entry
points to for people for stoicism I was
wondering
how could we you console or help someone
or try to introduce people our friends
to stoicism without sounding preachy
without being a busybody that's a great
question
yeah it is I think part of it is you
know don't place too much stress in any
one single interaction so you you know
you you suggest to them hey this has
been helpful for me and then you kind of
leave it at that and if they respond to
it and they ask questions now you've got
an opening but you don't you don't
follow up and like nag you think because
if they're already having a rough time
they don't need you you know help you
know helping them in that way if they're
not ready to hear it and you know this
is this comes up a lot like I am you
know Massimo I think you could talk
about this too I have kids who are
teenagers and I you know I see the
struggles that they go through
I know that some of the things that we
study could be helpful for them but
trying to suggest anything to a teenager
is often productive so you have to like
you know they have to see some sort of
some sort of gain on their part in order
for them to take it on and so you know
just by acting in that way they see they
see me sitting around reading it they
know that I take it seriously they're a
little bit more prone to then be open to
it but only a little bit more yeah and
so I find a friend or a family member
that you want to reach or colleague you
know somebody at work
who you see is struggling you know I
think sort of a soft touch approach is
the way to go
yeah and I agree and one way to do the
soft touch approach is actually not
mentioned necessarily the stories at
least not at the beginning so I learned
that unless somebody unless it's a
different context like this one
obviously we're talking about stories
right but if it is in neutral context
where I don't expect people necessary to
be familiar with stories or to be but
you're interested in stores and then I
might bring up a notion a concept
without saying you know epictetus says
because yeah if it it says it doesn't
say much to other to a lot of people and
also it may be a turn-off but if you say
so I you know I've heard about this
notion that you know that it's useful to
to focus on things that under your
control what your agency is maximized
and then to try to develop an attitude
of you know accept and store the rest
it's like oh really does that come from
because that sounds very much like a
serenity prayer I know right but
actually you know it goes back 2,000
years blah blah and now you're into a
conversation so so I don't think I never
start by quoting scripture basically
that's that's what I'm suggesting as
Marcus or any system know that's
probably counterproductive and it's too
bad because people can benefit from the
stoic insight and it may not the direct
approach might not necessarily be the
best one unless again people ask you
that I mean now for these days for me
it's almost impossible to pretend that
I'm not practicing everybody that
purchased me know so now did yeah
look we got maybe a couple of minutes
one more question from mark yes can you
hear me yes yeah great well first thank
you very much this has been awesome my
question concerns the dichotomy of
control if you were to consider two
people practice and stoicism one of them
says that's out of my control there's
nothing I can do anyway and the second
person says they're going to do
everything within their power I was
wondering if you would consider it a
misunderstanding of stoicism to kind of
hide behind it to not ask yes definitely
as a matter of fact in ancient times
there was something called the idol
argument that Cicero talks about in on
favor and there's all sorts of examples
of it today where somebody will say like
well you know the doctor prescribed this
medicine for me but it's not really in
my control it see I'm either gonna get
better I'm not gonna get better so I
won't take the medicines hey Fred and
sure enough you're not likely to get
better
yeah and so there there's there's
there's a lot of things like that that
we can say just because something is out
of our control doesn't mean that we
shouldn't orient ourselves towards it
like epictetus says the use of
indifference is something that is in our
control though the attitude we take
towards or whether we try to at least do
our best in relationship but then you
know we realize that you know ultimately
those things are not entirely up to us
and they can go counter to whatever
expectations we might have that's right
all right Greg this has been a pleasure
it's been yeah like one in an hour if
you don't mind I'll invite you again at
some point because this looks like we
have lots of stuff to talk about sounds
like a great great idea great everybody
thanks for coming and joining us today
remember next week we're gonna have John
sellers and the art of living so that
should be fun as well or at least
interesting and you know informative and
other than that yeah yeah it's mine
version of fun might be different from
other people's in the meantime you know
stay safe and try to get over the
pandemic as best as you can
bye-bye
you